this is a fresh one and these are the
most dangerous because the fresh ones
Jamie's already laughing Brian Simpson
did throw his headphones off and ran out
of the room when he did because it burns
yes he got too deep he went too deep and
then Theo kept doing it yeah because his
nose is damaged also the one that he got
was not as potent correct the one that
we got with Brian is insanely potent you
want to get him right when you open them
because that's the most
potentially my sinuses it's gonna wreck
wait you just smelled the bottle
that's all we do
you smell the bottle put it about six
inches yeah
I told you bro I told her she promised
no joke
oh
oh God my eyes thank you Joe I
appreciate that
you know I wouldn't do that to you dog
you can't even do a nice bath yeah